what we don't talk about a lot is the
UFOs that are living under the sea I was
just thinking that same thing they're
doing the wi files yesterday on this
it's the
bermudo Uso look at you wow and so they
unidentified submerged object object and
they said it's around the Bermuda
Triangle and and they don't know what
it's it's run by but the
wian and it could it could have been
Atlantis but also what was really
fascinating was they had uh Christopher
Columbus his diary he had a sighting
that's right and he had a sighting and
that he said a light was under the water
like there's no lights in [__] 1470
whatever
Usos is something that I was from the
highest ranking military individuals
that I've ever spoken with in private
over a decade ago I was urged to know
and understand and look at that UFOs are
one thing unidentified flying object but
Usos are the core of what's going on
that's what was conveyed to me now why
that's important why did we change it to
UAP instead of UFO unidentified flying
object now unidentified anomalous
phenomena okay here's why because they
are what's called all domain we track
UFOs with satellites pointed outward in
space we track UFOs in air and we track
UFOs under the water all domain space
air and CA unidentified anomalous
phenomena covers all domain so that's
why they did that once something
breaches those different you know areas
they call it transm medium when there's
no inertial effect or they call it
transm medium if it can do that go
between all three so you see no inertial
effect which is no slowdown from space
to air to sea and a good example of that
would be the tick tac UFO event with
Commander David fraver my good old
friend and Buddy and the guy that filmed
it Commander Chad under W it's the most
famous UFO case ever now what people
forget is the Tic Tac UFO wasn't one
object it was a series of weeks of
tracking things dropping from outer
space down to sea level in less than a
second without a sonic boom trans medium
no inertial effect no Sonic Boom so that
was happening during that whole thing of
the Tic Tac UFO event series but
remember this people might not have
caught my first report George and I
broke that story before the New York
Times there was something under the
water for sure there it was docking they
were docking was the word told me it was
something a Uso under the water can they
have they tracked them moving at high
speed underwater yes 100% so there the
resistance of the water isn't an issue
correct is this the one where the Tic
Tac video actually has there are four
more minutes of the video that's the
gimbal I explain to you the difference
2015 was the gimbal 2004 was the Tic Tac
in 2015 was the Gimbal and the goast
those releases the gimbal is that one
that mechanically rotates Against the
Wind and you hear the pilot saying like
holy [__] 120,000 there's a fleet of
them yeah right so what he's saying and
I know to be true is that in that
footage where you see the gimbal
rotating it looks like the Bob Lazar
Flying Saucer I mean it's like shaped
like a saucer when it rotates in front
of it is I think five other objects that
were kind of like um what do you call it
when you when you you go along like a
caravan or UFOs or something escorts
right a flock a flock I don't know what
you call like a flock a UFOs uos a flap
um yeah so there there there were on
that day there were other UFOs in front
of that one and there's four extra
minutes of footage that hasn't been
released to the public and again I'm not
in a position to release that I do
believe that if we put enough pressure
Maybe the dod and the government will
declassify that and put it forward
that's what we're fighting for but hell
yeah dude that was the gimbal it's it's
a good case what do you think is the
maybe some speculation on why whatever
these things they're um driving the
crafts why do they want to be so
secretive like why are they hiding
themselves from us yeah speculation mode
right because I I don't have direct
communication with the aliens you know I
don't know who's operating them but um
here's what I notice what I noticed is
that the pattern that we have seen
through human history has been one of
observation and not direct
intervention typically there are cases
of intervention you go all the way back
in history to like Alexander the Great
and like basically like Shields of fire
like beaming down wall to break it
through so he can invade I don't know I
wasn't there that's history right but in
modern history you have these UFOs
landing and communicating with with the
children you have the aerial School
event which is is powerful I know the
two girls that were standing right there
by these beings that was in Africa yeah
I keep messing this up the the exact
country that it was uh zimb I think
Zimbabwe it was Rua I don't know I've
been I've been to Africa a bunch man and
I got confused Zimbabwe I watched a
documentary yeah yeah was Zimbabwe yeah
so so basically the these um children at
the time lisel and Salma they're
incredible human beings they were like
within a meter like three plus feet of
these beings but my point is this is
that there seems to be an observational
program uh that is the primary thing now
some people say that's prepp in the
battlefield some people say they're
studying us look we're the greatest show
in the solar system planet Earth I mean
come on man we got it all war [__]
fighting the Kardashians we got
everything right so why wouldn't you
watch us now do you go up to an ant hill
and do you like talk with the ants no
you you know you study them what do you
do to cattle you feed them you water
them you give them antibiotics and then
you [__] eat them so I don't know
what is going on but I do know that
there is direct contact with a lot of
people and what's said to them has kind
of been ubiquitous they they they kind
of repeat the same kind of stuff whoever
these people are that are flying these
things now can we trust what they tell
us oh [__] no man trust is earned and if
you're not revealing yourselves you're
not revealing yourselves the true
architects of the secrecy would be the
visitors themselves you should read a
book called childhood H's End by Arthur
C Clark you know who he he Arthur C
Clark was a guy like a futurist he like
predicted the Internet it's got some
great books one's called childhood's end
and in that book he's got these craft
and what they do is they post up in the
sky and for Generations they just sit
there acclimate Humanity to their
presence because they got a little dirty
secret that they that they know it's
going to be hard to breach the second
they meet humans I don't want to ruin
the book but they look like [__]
demons wow so I don't know why the
message that the aliens that visited
that school in Africa gave to the
children was you're trashing the planet
you have to change this and that was so
much before that was a thing in in
humanity right I asked um LEL one of the
two girls like why do you think you were
shown them by the way it was like a
projection in their minds and it was
like mesmerizing like they the second
they turned to their friends it
disappeared so if you believe them or
not it did happen but if you believe
them or not like I asked her why do you
think they said that to you you know
it'd be weird like I don't know what and
if I was an alien I don't know what I
would say to somebody I'd probably give
him a t-shirt or something why did you
say
that what are you supposed to do with
that and then you made a good point it
was so long ago what year was 80s early
' 80s dude I'm sorry my fact are scram
I'm TI wasn't there like 30 school
children there's a bunch there's a b
yeah full school yeah but so she said to
me I think I'm doing doing it now I go
what do you mean she goes just talking
about it yeah I think that was the point
spreading the word spread the word the
other thing it makes me think of is that
old Twilight Zone from the 60s where
they find the book that the aliens had
to serve man was the name of the book
they translated it and then they were
working on translating what was inside
of it and they're like oh they're here
to help us and at the end the famous
line is it's a cookbook no to Ser man
dude will you will you text me that
episode uh the title of it like ser my
God I I really hope we're not food man
and by the way you taste better than me
so go with him first man do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce for your butthole plus steo
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butt whole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude